all right stand by we're going live with
the intro
are you out of your mind here's the
debate you're upset they're saying We
Believe
[Music]
cinnamon we're live all right fantastic
folks we have a special one here for you
episode number 154 with the one and only
uh George Saint Pierre in the topic of
discussion as a goat uh if not decode I
uh send a question on Twitter uh
yesterday saying uh who would you say is
the greatest of all time when it comes
down to UFC and it was gsbjsp Johnson
everywhere the name was coming up and
there's a few things folks you need to
know and this is one you may want to
stick around and get all your peers on
because there's a way for you to win
this signed glove by GSP uh it's all
based on Super Chat and I'll tell you
here in a minute on what that is but
there's a few things you need to know
for some of you guys that don't follow
UFC but you know what UFC is this is a
man who is the eight he's got eight
career Knockouts six career submission
13 fight win streak 13 title fight wins
nine consecutive title defenses two
Division World Champion that's
welterweight and middleweight I think
you were held as has been going for the
most undefeated days in a row was I want
to say 2 204 days I may be off by a few
days but some ridiculous streak of how
long you went with that with that being
said our guest today the legend the goat
George Saint Pierre thank you so much
for being on the podcast thank you for
for having me guys yes and by the way
here's what our outcomes of today's
podcast this is what our outcome is a
successful podcast today in my like
every time I go on a podcast I want to
create a certain standard success for us
today is If by the end of the podcast we
can come up with a specific dollar
amount to get you and khabib to fight
so if we can figure out the dollar
amount then we get this to Dana and some
of the guys who knows what can happen we
can get the two of you guys if I will
talk about are you comfortable with that
outcome
but here's what we're doing folks if you
do want to get this uh autograph uh uh
by GSP the glove a hundred percent the
super chat today is going to his charity
that he has uh the George Saint Pierre
uh Foundation he had no idea I just
literally announced it today I haven't
even brought it up to you right before I
ask you do you have a charity you said
yes you do and you support folks who
were yeah uh at Young athletes that
trains uh for Olympic uh because a lot
of the time they don't have enough money
to travel for competitions and also
anti-bullying it's an organization that
gives money to the organizations and
that that I support I love it so folks
you put up the Super Chat whatever the
Super Chat is 100 of what we're going to
give to the charity at the end we're
going to take all the super chat
minimums got to be 20 bucks to be part
of this uh uh raffle that we'll do at
the end sanville at the end if you can
gather the names we'll do the raffle
somebody's gonna get this glove and
we'll ship it over to you no matter
where you are in the world and we'll
give the money to the charity so uh and
we may do some colors at the end for
people to call and ask some questions
having said that George
um with everything that's going on right
now with with the anticipation of uh
people wanting to see you come back and
you got a birthday coming up in two
weeks what do you what do you think
about when you see all everybody in
media is like dude you know what it's
like it's kind of like a Indie NBA there
was one game everybody wanted to see one
final I know you're a sports guy
everybody wanted to see the final of
LeBron and Kobe we never saw it we got
Jordan and Magic we got magic and bird
we got Brady and Peyton we got a lot of
these guys that face but we never got
Kobe and LeBron and LeBron says it was
my fault because the year that he was
supposed to go he lost he didn't make it
to the end Kobe did his part I think a
lot of people would be curious to see a
fight between you and khabib what do you
think about all these conversations
coming up to see the two of you guys
fight well it's uh
it's always a question of timing we
we've tried to make it happen
when I retired a year after I retired we
approached UFC with that idea and khabib
was on board I was on board but the UFC
had a other plan they wanted to
did in a business point of view it makes
sense because I wanted to keep khabib
active because to keep the ball rolling
they knew that if it would I would only
come back for maybe one fight you know
what I mean
the rather
keep cabin active I guess and not taking
the risk and I understand that and
therefore that's why I believe it did
not materialize however when khabib
fought Justin gaichi and beat Justin
gaichi I think he took everybody by
surprise by uh he took he announced his
retirement and if I believe even his own
people didn't know that he was going to
make that move because I remember I was
doing the the French commentator on on
the channel back home and I thought that
after a fight maybe he would have called
me out you know what I mean I had
butterflies in my stuff you're expecting
that you wanted that almost I don't know
if I wanted that but if you would have
done it maybe I would like I would have
I wouldn't have any choice you know
because it's like a challenge that I was
looking for a long time yeah it didn't
happen at the time that we tried to make
it happen but now I was I think a year
after that it was still fresh I was like
I'll do it you know but it did not
happen and you retired now
what happened uh a few years after I I I
I I was offered to fight uh uskard allow
you in a in a boxing year so a modified
rule of boxing match
and um of course I'm
still under contract with UFC a few
years after I retired so
um what happened now because khabib is
retired and I'm retired so now the UFC
Dana called me and he's like oh now
would you be interested by khabib he
asked me he called me but I thought it
was strange because I never wanted to do
it and now because he called me for that
reason I was like I didn't want to do it
but I told Dana just to see what
happened because I was curious you know
it's always a chess game when when the
promoter calls you it's it's a that's
the world where I live in so I didn't
say no I said okay let me think about it
so I wait and I heard in the news that
they and the way Dana talked to me it
was like khabib already accepted but it
wasn't true it was just going to fish
with me to with fishing see how to make
the fight happen so they knew now that
we were both the retire so for them it
was an opportunity to make a big money
fight
so I I said I'm gonna think about it and
I I wait a few days and I sent the media
the Ali abdullah's abdelaziz I came out
publicly and said hey now George want to
fight but now we we already retired he
said so it was all Bs you know Dana
kind of lie to me
they didn't approach khabib first they
approached me first to make it happen so
you actually think Dana kind of lied to
you no no no I think I know now straight
up yeah 100 100 and you feel comfortable
just putting that out there um it's the
game that's the nature of the game the
promotion you gotta realize he's
promoting it's not lying it's in a way
of saying if I have khabib in his mind
he's thinking if you say yes I know I
can convince could be because I know
what I'm going to pay him so in his mind
it's a yes it is lying but I I
understand what the universe that's how
the business works and I'm you now I
know now I I you know I'm I'm an
experienced guys and I've been doing it
for 20 plus years exactly so I I know I
know the game so that's why I didn't
want to do it but I didn't want to say
no because the reason why he called me
because they know add a lot of eat
because they didn't let me fight Oscar
the lawyer so everybody was complaining
he's like why you didn't want to let
George fight Oscar de laoyo in in the
boxing fight
and and you hold them up so they know
now by saying say you could have go back
and tell the media say oh why would I
let George go fight in boxing when he
doesn't want to fight khabib for me for
with the with the UFC so he would have
had a good reason that's why he did this
he did this it was a strategic move of
this part yeah yeah it's always like
this with with with Dana I mean I like I
like that person now now I'm I'm retired
we've we talked about it when I was
inducted to the Hall of Fame I was like
now it's it's cool we can have a we talk
about the old days and and saying the
real thing but when I was competing it
was always when the phone rang and I saw
that you know what I was like shoot what
is it gonna come with it how long ago
was this yes off until
um like until like a year a year okay
yeah yeah got it so but now it's over
now so now we can talk like two friends
and and so how has the relationship
changed when you said he would he would
call you you would be like oh [ __ ] what
does he want now when you were active
versus now the the relationship must
have changed to some some extent right I
did change a lot um
they know it's normal is the best
promoter in the world there's a reason
why he's the best promoter in the world
he's the best I don't care Don can you
put anybody I think they know he's the
best in the world can sell ice to an
Eskimo you know he's just that good he's
very smart
but to be a good promoter you need to to
use certain tools to be tricky sometimes
and he did what he had to do for the
best of his own interests but I did what
I had to do for the best of my own
interests so sometimes it it conflict
each other that's why we get some some
arguments sometimes but
it's only business for me you know so
let's go back to it so if today you got
a call is there a dollar amount that
would get you to entertain fighting
straight up with khabib if he was also
open to a UFC card like full-on the same
way you fought all these years would you
entertain a fight today with khabib no I
would not zero not zero 10 million bucks
zero is nothing like 30 million bucks I
don't care seriously yeah I can have a
credit card that can I can use for them
but would you want to do that with
anybody no because no nobody and I'm
gonna tell you why there is no price for
my health and I'm not only talking about
physical health yeah I what took the
most out of me doing my active years of
of competition competition it was the
stress I had a lot of stress and I
always told myself because it's an
addiction you become addicted to this
thing it's like a drug winning
especially winning a title winning a
fight it's
crazy man I can't describe how it makes
you feel but it can become an addiction
that's why you see a lot of these
Fighters they they retire away too late
way too late they don't know when they
don't know because they become addicted
to this and I always told myself
I draw the line I said after 40 years
old at 40 it's finished no matter what
happened it's funny it's finished
because I know
that my best years are probably behind
me you know of course when I retired I
felt that I might have left money on the
table maybe I could have stayed there
for two three four more fights maybe or
maybe I would have got hurt on the
process I don't know but I don't want to
roll the the dice and take the risk I
rather retire when my stuck is high when
I'm healthy and I can enjoy the rest of
my life and also on a business
perspective when you you retire on top
you turn around you have a lot of
opportunities that opens to you A lot of
these doors might be closed if you
retire retire on a losing Street very
good that's why I think it's very sad
when I see some Legend retire too late
because first they lose their health
yeah you know they get brain damage it's
very sad to see and they lose these
opportunities that would have been open
to them if they would have retired on
top it's not a game we don't play in
fighting would you say you play fight
you play baseball you play basketball
but the the consequences of a loss in
this in this in this sport it's way more
dramatic than it is and another sport
for example George let me ask you two
things so
for you
um you know you look at somebody who
competes at the high level we typically
hear some stuff that people say oh that
guy's just so confident oh that guy's
got no fear or that guy's got the reason
why he's doing this so he trained so
hard because he just wants to beat
everybody so bad and then deep down
inside when you go find out actually why
this guy trained so hard is because this
person is driven by doesn't want to get
humiliated publicly so this person's
like there's no way I'm going to lose
publicly everybody's going to watch me I
train extra because I'm not going to be
publicly humiliated it's just not going
to happen to me right uh and some you
know you said something about the fact
that you're always going to a fight you
got this weird feeling you're afraid you
oh my god what if this goes wrong what
if that goes around the only fight you
ever didn't feel this way was Sarah
where you're like you went I was like I
was good I'm like I'm not gonna lose to
this game that's the one you lost
because you didn't go on Paranoid right
that Dynamic yeah what did you ever have
a moment in your career
that you not necessarily fear but in a
moment where you were fighting something
happened to the body or either on the
fear end or humiliation end where you
said [ __ ] I'm I I don't what am I like
what was this all about that either
brought in the best of you or the worst
of you humiliation as well as fear I
never liked to fight I never liked it
people like oh you're [ __ ] thinking
no man I never liked it I love the
freedom the freedom that it brings me I
love the fact that it keeps me in shape
I love the confidence that this sport
gives me I love to go to the gym to
train with my training partner the
camaradri that I have
I love the science of the game the The
Art of War the the the chess game of
fighting
I love that I love that that I have
access of things that most people do not
have access I love that but in order to
preserve that I need it to go take that
walk and fight in the Octagon but I
hated it I despised it I never liked it
I never enjoyed it a second never liked
it I like to win
the worst part for me the worst day of
the year for me is the days that I'm
fighting it's terrible it's unbearable
and and when I was young
I remember when I started my career
because I wanted to be Champion but I
needed to go through that pain to that
grind in order to achieve what I what I
wanted to achieve my goal and I was
looking around to all my training
partners and a lot of them it seems to
me that I was making fun I was like you
guys are like psychopath because they
it's either they were acting or telling
me the truth but
I I felt I was not in the right field of
work because they were they were telling
me Oh I'm happy to do this I can't wait
to fight and I'm like you guys are crazy
man me I'm scared like I I can't wait
that it's over but I don't like that
process and I I try to
seek the help of sport psychologists at
the time because I was like maybe I'm
not in in the right lane and the sport
psychologist used to tell me George try
to to brainwash me he goes George
stop saying you're afraid you're you're
excited and I was like it does not apply
here you know because you're excited
when you're in Montreal and it's minus
20 degree and you know that next week
you're going on vacation in the beach I
will be excited or you know what I mean
I will be excited if I'm fasting for
three days and I'm about to eat my
favorite dish I'm excited I can't wait
but I'm not excited
to go fight in a cage not knowing if I
will be badly hurt or humiliated I'm
afraid and then I start realizing I said
you know what there is no courage
without fear I should not be afraid to
admit that I'm afraid wow and I realize
also that that fear that I had makes me
way more
way more dangerous because I realized
that it it enhanced my power my reaction
time my decision making making time that
fear gives me
the drive to train harder in the fear
that my opponent trained even harder
than me helps me prepare even better in
the fear that my opponent is is getting
is doing more than me so so what what
are you afraid of so because for me
uh certain words have evolved the
meaning of certain words have evolved
for me over the years okay it's the
meaning of Love did him in the same to
me at 10 then 20 then 30 then 40 then
today with four kids the meaning of
competition was very different in my
teens than 20s and 30s and 40s than
today the meaning of fear fear for me
recently has been very different it's
been a very different meaning of fear uh
uh because fear to me it's been more
from the perspective of I ask myself why
why in certain things that I'm doing
like why why do you not stop what is the
fear that makes you not stop the biggest
fear I had was the fear of my kids dying
without them one with my dad dying
without my kids ever meeting my dad like
because I never met his dad so that fear
drove the hell out of me right so I
wanted to understand the relationship
with fear what was one of your biggest
fears like did you you know how you go
to sleep and there's that one nightmare
that you replay in your mouth dude this
cannot happen What Fear haunted you the
most
the fear change over the year when I was
young
and I wanted to become Champion it was
the fear of being humiliated you know
what I mean that was the fear and that's
pretty much the fear that I had for
the most part of my career you know to
be humiliated
then it changed to the fear of
maybe at one point because you become
more aware of
of of of what can happen you become
smarter and it's not necessarily a good
thing when you're a fighter to not to be
smart but I'll try to explain the best
as I can is you realize that man I've
been doing this for a long time you
don't know the consequences of of brain
damage in long terms and you know in my
fights I have generally always come come
on top or at almost all the time and I
don't get punched too much but in
practice you know you have to go through
people always say oh your fight or you
go you beat your opponent pretty good
without taking so much damage it's true
but in practice you practice every day
that's what you know to get hit on the
head every day the impact the stress
right the stress I think it's it's one
of the things that we don't talk about
it's crazy you're on Fighter's flight
you know like do I have a a a little
stress it helps you improve but to be on
that crazy fear stress of of protection
that that is like a Fighter's fight that
you always have someone that that you
know in a in a few weeks that you're
gonna fight that might kill you and
after that person once you beat him
there's another one and another one and
another one so you constantly feel
threatened threatening and for me I was
obsessed it's one of the things that
helped me perform better is I was
obsessed by the idea of of being the
best I was obsessed and being a champion
being a fighter it's a very selfish life
because everything is oriented towards
you me me me me how I can get better if
I do this is it gonna help me improve I
was com I was completely insane
everything I was doing at the time was
to get me a better fighter and my
perspective is change because now I'm
thinking about the future like I don't
want to do this anymore I want to be I'm
healthy you know what I mean how old
were you when you started thinking that
I was a teenager I was a teenager when I
first saw Rose Gracie I knew that's what
I wanted to do for a living and
immediately my life shifted you know I
never been diagnosed
but I I think I'm a little bit uh
obsessive compulsive okay yeah OCD I'm
not that kind of guy who opened the door
10 times you know but I have these
things for example
um the other give you some example like
how how the brain works and I think it's
a good thing when you're an athlete but
in society could be a bad thing for
example now I tried to detach myself
from that but it's hard sometimes like
I'm driving my car
and I tell myself and I tell myself I'm
gonna hold my breath for uh 500 meter
and I
at four four 450 meter I hit traffic
I'm like I'm holding my breath
I'm like [ __ ] I'm going on the side and
yeah I do with the extra 50 meter and
now I can this is not normal man this is
not normal because you're playing a game
with yourself you're playing a game with
yourself I'm playing my game but it's
stupid but [ __ ] like this I do but but
now I still or the other day I go to um
my cousin I go pick up my cousin and
it's cool
I'm opening the door for the parent that
comes out with their kids
and I'm holding the door and there is a
kids that that that comes and doesn't go
through he hold the door for me he goes
Go sir and I'm like no no you go kid you
go okay now you say no sir I'm like I'm
thinking of saying if I would have been
younger I was like hell no I'm not
[ __ ] moving until you go first but
he's like [ __ ] and I'm thinking I'm
saying
and it it was hard for me to go or no no
I I went first and I lost but I was like
oh it's hard this is not normal but I
think my brain works like that yes so
you had like a Russian standoff with uh
yeah when I get this like like eight
years old like I'm rolling
no no please go first and his dad was
there I was like then I was like okay
thank you and I play like play like
nothing ever but in my mind I was like
if that eight kid eight-year-old kid
only knew he's like by the way have you
ever seen a movie uh Prefontaine you
ever seen the prefonte the marathon the
marathon that would run like three
milers not one mile he was like his
coach is like you're better at three in
the whole field night story with the
shoes so there's a scene in the movie
where he's telling these kids so here
you guys can run with me and you're
gonna practice and all this stuff and
he's at this high school and he's an
adult at this point he's a champion
everybody knows and he's running and
this one kid keeps trying to get ahead
of him and he says no slow down you
can't run ahead of me he says the kid is
12 years old this guy's 30 years I said
he keeps trying to keep kind of you
can't get ahead of me you have to stand
behind me he says what is the and by the
way psychologically he did not want to
buy in the fact that even anybody that
could beat him so they run at the end he
still tells the kid you can't run ahead
of me so he keeps running faster than
him these are the little quirks of the
goats that it's so hard to explain that
somebody will write a book and will call
you you know hypomanic you're mentally
off where's this you're that yeah but
the world admires seeing folks who are
able to take the game to the levels that
you took it to I see it like a little
bit like an
like an addiction sort of it's something
that I needed in the past in order to
perform in my field of work but now I
have to let go of this thing and it's
very hard to let go man like there's
little things that like that that
happened to me and people don't notice
it because I it's it happened inside of
my head but it's hard man like like
my some of my friends knows and they
play a trick with me sometimes they like
like I'm eating sometime and sometimes I
notice I like everything lined up in my
table and my friend like let's say I go
to bedroom when I come back they they
realize these are good friends the
configuration of the table and they all
laughing it so when I come I
automatically put it up yeah and they're
all like you know like stuff like that I
mean it's funny but
that's the the thing I think it's part
of my of my of my duty now to trying to
try to let go why though why
I have to because if I don't I will be
able to function and like it my life has
changed now it's not about becoming the
best fighter in the world like I have to
to blend in with the other people you
know what I mean otherwise it could be
damageable but but you're only 40 40
years old I mean you you still got 60
more years to live I agree but I think
it will not happen overnight I need to I
need to slowly adapt to this and I need
to release release it I won't be able to
release everything from A to Z I think
it will take time so go back to go back
and ask like was there a life event I
know you've talked about bullying as a
kid when you were going through but was
there a life event that got you to say I
have to be the best at something that's
something it's it to say I'm gonna be
the best at this game I'm gonna go all
the way to the top was there certain
life event was it I'm doing it for my
mom I'm doing it for my dad you know
some this kid said this and I watched a
video the other day that's going viral I
don't know if you guys seen it or not
this thing got like a couple hundred
million views this guy who's a boxer
he's fighting the former Bully from high
school the bully from high school comes
into the rink who knows how to fight but
he's fighting the kid who used to bully
all the time but the kid that he used to
bully all the time is now a very good
fighter so the bully's still trying to
bully him and this guy's destroying him
I'm gonna give you the video to play it
here in a minute it's a great video I'll
find it I'll show it to you but what was
it for you that said I have to be the
best was it something you were born with
or did an event in your life say I'm
gonna show the world what I'm all about
it's a hard question to ask
I think when you care about something
and I'm I'm a very by Nature competitive
person and I cared about about
martial art I I
um I got really inspired by Royce
Grayson and I think
I'm gonna try to explain to you how I
got exp inspired by him so maybe you
will understand how your brain works
I um when I was a kid I was bullied of
course and uh you were bullied as a kid
yes I was I was Batman in Montreal
you're saying growing up yeah South
Shore yeah I was bully I was at instead
of focusing on what the teacher was
explaining in front of the class I had
to
focus on how I'm gonna get my books from
my locker reach the bus before the kids
wait for me the older kids they had a
program at the school where I was it's
called Uh in French
it's a basically it's kids that were
older than us that used to redo their
grade because they they couldn't pass
yeah so they were like three sometimes
three two three years older than us but
at the time when you're a kid when
you're like seven eight years old it's a
big difference of course you have
someone who's 10 years old and you're
eight or eleven it's not like you're 25
and 28 no no you're 30 older than you
yeah
exactly it's a huge difference so that a
lot of issues with this kid and at that
time I was you know I was most of my
friends were a geek and intellectual
people and I was eight years old you're
saying yeah they were like kids that
were more you know like Star Wars and
you know like I like that stuff you know
like mathematic and I was like that too
but I was very good in sport you know I
always been like in my amongst my friend
I was the one that was pretty maybe the
most athletic guy in my friend so
and therefore I was
very often in situation that I uh when
there was they had we had trouble with
these older kid I was the one stepping
in to you know try to you know to fix it
but unfortunately it didn't go my way
very often so on in the street I have a
losing record if I if I look in my in my
child childhood but I start martial art
as a self-defense and uh so if I if I
then the self-defense become quickly a
passion because things were not going
well for me at home and they were not
going well at school either the only
place where I felt I was valuable I was
I had value and I was doing well it was
in the dojo the place where I was
training that was the only place that it
was very rewarding for me to be there so
it became a passion
and then part of your identity almost
yes and and I learned that the
discipline there because I grew up with
a lot of anger a lot of you know
negativity and and at that time I I I
felt a little bit oppressed you know I
didn't realize how lucky I was to be
born in a country like Canada with all
the opportunity I felt like I would I I
didn't see the world same way I was
seeing it
and if I fast forward later
one of my my karate teacher died and
when I saw Royce Gracie
I saw the first UFC I was a teenager I
saw a guy that did not look very
intimidating
but he was fighting these other guys
that were much much bigger than him
they look like bullied to me and he
looked like the victim yeah oh right so
when I saw him winning the first
tournament in the UFC
I saw him do things that I was never
able to do at the time
like Revenge taking a river the Revenge
defending himself against the bully so I
believe that's why I got very inspired
by what he did and right away I was like
man this guy is like my hero I want to
become like him I want to be him because
I was not able to do that when I was
young I want to be I want to do like
what he did so I wanted to follow his
path and right away I told my friend at
the time said that's what I want to do I
was already a black belt in karate by
what age uh I was around 13 years old
and this happened when I was
15 years old so I told my friends and I
want to become UFC champion they all
start laughing but by 13 being a black
belt because I did Karate as a kid and I
remember they gave I was like a brown
belt by like age 12 but was I really a
brown bear exactly that's my question
like were you really a black belt by age
13 like a legit badass or was it kind of
that belt is only there to tie up your
ghee it doesn't the system of belt it's
it's a it's a it's a reward system
business thing yeah and and you know in
reality the belt is supposed to be white
yeah but over the years because you
trained so hard over the years it become
dirty dirty dirty it becomes black you
don't have to change the belt like a
white yellow orange green what a
constant you want it to become natural
yes that's that's how it should be but
now they sell these belt because the
money now even they put stripe in it to
make another yeah in between yes it's a
business thing so it was a brown belt
with black stripes but I was 12 years
old and any 18 year olds are gonna kick
the [ __ ] out of me a hundred percent but
but what I mean is it's not because
you're you're an higher rank belt that
you're more of a badass it that it just
means that you might have more knowledge
than the lower uh rank belt it doesn't
mean you're necessarily a better fighter
but you know when you're a kid you know
what I mean there's a a factor of
strength maturity you know that there's
a lot of thing that plays out you know
can I revisit something we were talking
about just right off air and it has it
has to do with this concept of being the
best
right so you said I was obsessed with
being the best obsessed right and I I
come to think of uh what's the female
fight Rose Nami Eunice yeah there's this
clip of her
um
even Rogan talked about it about she's
just she's in the ring saying I'm the
best I'm the best I'm the best have you
seen her do this yes she says this I'm
the best I'm the best
you said there wasn't a lot that
separated the guy who was number two and
you were number one physically yeah
right there there's not a lot that
separates the elite athletes physically
how much does does mentally being
mentally prepared everything you were
talking about earlier what separates the
goat the greatest of all time from All
Stars I believe it's a lot of factor but
the reason if I think Rose namajunez was
saying I'm the best I'm the best
I call I think it's it's called James
Lynch Theory and I'm going to explain to
you
we know that your mind can dictate your
body what to do if I'm thirsty I I'm
saying to myself I'm thirsty grab that
bottle and drink water
but the opposite is true too my actions
can change
my division that I have of myself
and I use that every before every single
of my fights
because before every fight I'm terrified
I'm extremely uncomfortable I'm scared
however there's a routine that I have in
my locker room
and the day of the fight
my trainers know my friend knows I'm
putting on a mask I'm putting on an act
they all know I'm scared and very often
I'm telling them as I [ __ ] what the hell
I'm doing here
and they're laughing because it's the
same thing all the time the same the
same movie that plays all the time but
I'm playing a role so they ask me even
the way I most of before every fight
normally I don't have a good night of
sleep because I'm too scared I'm running
scenarios in my mind and they always ask
me I'll I'll fresh you feel today I'm
always like I feel great man I'm ready
to kick ass it's gonna be a good day and
I'm playing that role of a kind of a
superhero who's not afraid who's excited
to find out how he's gonna win the whole
day until I meet until it's time to take
my walk to the octagon and I have a
routine that I do
when the UFC guys come and um come to
get me before I am
I walk he goes safe here he kick the
door he goes safety are you up next are
you ready I'm like yes one minute sir I
go in the bathroom and I go in the
bathroom to look myself in the mirror
and normally I before I used to have a
ghee I was putting my gear you know as I
was doing this but I'm telling myself
all the reasons why I think I will win
the fight even if it's not true
because I don't know what the other guys
does even if it's not true as long as I
believe it it will transform the way I
see myself and will make me more
confident so I'm telling myself I train
harder than him I put more time than he
did I have better trainers I have better
training Partners I flew in all these
killers and training camp to try to test
me and I got through Like A Champion you
know there is no way I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna lose this fight I'm faster I'm
I'm I'm I have a better IQ fighting IQ
than he than he does you know I'm
stronger and for whatever the reason is
and then for one minute I telling all
this as I'm looking down and I'm putting
on an act then when I get out of the
bathroom I'm not the same person that I
was when I when I got in
it's show time and now I'm on a
difference Power phone I'm on what I
call cruise control so it that's what it
that's what it is about you know what I
mean you need to transform yourself
psychologically that's how I that's
that's what I did so when Rose is I'm
the best I'm the best that's why I think
she does she's trying to transform
herself telling that repeatedly in order
to start believing it you know who used
to say that a lot Diego Sanchez used to
be yes yes I don't know if you remember
Diego he was fun to watch man there was
something unique about watching that guy
he had a good streak at one point and
you know why because in fighting it and
I think in everything in life when you
want to achieve something that is
difficult you need to go all in it's
confidence is a very very important
thing that's why you see some guys that
are good in the gym but when they get in
when when the light comes up they can
pull the trigger confidence for me if I
can make an analogy is like
let's say you have someone I have all
the skills in the world but no
confidence it's like someone who has a
lot for example a lot of money in his
bank account but no way to access his
bank account so it's useless
so when you have the confidence and the
the skills now the magic Can Happen by
the way I want to show this video but
you were saying for something about your
coach you're like man I'm just scared
all this stuff have you seen the video
the scene we're not going to show that
one there's a scene with you you're
telling your coach it's my my groin I
pull my groin and the coach tells you I
don't care am I adductor muscle I don't
care hit him with your groin hit him
with your groin do you know that that's
what his coach told him yeah he stays in
the corner you're saying this and the
coach is like hit him with the groin are
we able to watch it no I want to show
you this other fight about this bully so
check this out so that guy to the right
he's talking we got to listen to the
audio turn on the audio and Rewind it a
little bit the bully so the bully is the
guy in the black shirt but you got to
hear the audio
you'll never beat me again listen
Watch What Happens
the guy in a black shirt is a bully in
high school the other guy knows what
he's doing now watch
you see the difference in skill it's not
even close but you know what guys I'm
gonna tell you the truth I mean most
people they they might glorify this me I
don't like I don't like to see this oh
let me tell you
yeah the part that makes me feel
uncomfortable about this
I don't I do not like this because
I happen to be in a similar situation
yeah
the the bully is a bully because maybe
that's the only way you learn how to
communicate maybe get you don't know I I
and and I I've I've trained my I changed
my mind over that because I remember
growing up I wanted to to one day take
my revenge and beat up the people who
bully me
but it's a true story I'm gonna tell you
one day I was driving they they used
I'll go back into it will be zero to
explain when I was uh one of the guy
that used to beat me up it was on the
bus it was um beat me up in the bus very
often and not only beat me up it was
very mental uh painful mentally for me
because it was humiliating me it was
like telling me shouting me names and
stuff like that yes in front everybody
because the cool guy were sitting in the
back and the the guy were not that cool
were in the front I was in the front it
was in the back so when it was shouting
stuff at me everybody could hear and I
was on the spot it was very humiliating
and something was hurting me yeah one
day I I came back from school with a
black Iron
my dad took me he say now you're gonna
tell me what what happened I never I
never
snitch nobody but one time I did I said
yeah there's a guy in the bus I can't
say his name he said he beat me up on
the bus and I'm from a small town
everybody knows everybody so my dad did
the unthinkable he found out where the
kids live
went to see
the dad he knock at the door
when the door opened my dad told me the
server he said when the door opened
could see that
that dad answered the door but it was he
said he was a bad atmosphere that that
was drunk smell alcohol and he could see
right away that
the kid probably grew up with his Dad no
mother and probably the way that he
learned how to communicate was from his
dad so I was just a collateral damage
you know what I mean
but at that time I was young I didn't
realize that it's later I become more
mature and when he told me that I
remember he was telling me that
so he tells me he told me that he talked
to to the dad and he's gonna stop
bullying me but the the day after I go
on the bus what do you think happened ah
you went to snitch to your father now I
had to fight him again I got beat up
again and I got humiliated again so he
didn't do any good to me yeah fast
forward a few years after I'm driving my
car on sale Boulevard on the cellar
corner sherbrook there's a guy begging
for money like they they wash your
window you know
so I look at him and he looked at me and
he saw who he saw me and I know he knew
he knew who I become so I go I go like
this I park my car on the side and I'm
walking and I could sit by his body
language he was like [ __ ] like I don't
know what to do you know like he felt
like like
you look like a like a like someone who
was who was very scared so I look I say
I tell his name I say what you doing
here man it's how things does not go
well for me you know I was like I need
help I given money I had in my pocket
wow I said listen when I was young man
everybody wanted to be like you you were
like the cool guy you were taller than
everybody or you know you you you have a
lot of potentials what the hell where is
where is your pride how come you end up
here it's I know things doesn't go well
now so I said get out of here man I
don't want to see you there you know
what I mean so I get back in my car and
I laugh and this make me feel much
better than if I would have beat beat
them up yes because you know what I mean
I wouldn't not want to if I wanted to I
could have kicked his ass but why why is
it it's a difference though there's one
difference though with the story that I
see because I'm fully with you you know
on the story you said because you know
you see certain friends that are
bullying you when you were small and
you're like you know oh you ain't gonna
do [ __ ] all these dreams you keep
dreaming you ain't gonna do nothing
so but he stayed he was down when you
met him the second time around yeah the
last time around this guy still coming
acting like a bully and he's being
reminded so the the level of this
sometimes in life because what's the
alternative let's get bullied again your
entire life because that's a very
emotional thing you know very emotional
and bullying comes in different ways one
is the fighting one is words I am one is
status one is family I came from a
divorce family and I'm Armenian Middle
Eastern nobody was getting a divorce who
you were you you ain't gonna do [ __ ] so
I joined the army I had the freaking
same attitude as well and then some of
those guys came back who were bullying
and you're sitting out to them what
victory do I have to show how much more
successful I am there's no reason what
you did that story it's such a freaking
emotional story right there when you
tell a story on how what was his
reaction by the what happened to that
guy afterwards because that's the part
okay he came to my parent or my parents
live yeah after a few months you wanted
to talk to me I'm from a small town you
know where I live but my parents said
George does not live here anymore for
it's been a long time so he goes hey can
you tell him I found a job now things go
well so there's a bad ending to the
story and um I remember I told on Joe
Rogan at that time and but there's a bad
ending I went a few years after on
another street corner and I see him
again and I turned my window and I was
like I tell him to say hey what the hell
he goes still back oh things doesn't go
well I'm like shoot he's back in but
what I don't like is the fact that
sometimes the bully
I think it's ignorance you know what I
mean it's it's their ignorance
of ignorance ignorance in a way that
they don't know how painful it is they
don't know yeah
how damageable it is what they're doing
you know like this guy over there we
still act like a bully but I think
he's kind of an enormous guy he doesn't
understand and the other guy I think
should be the better man you know I'm
not saying let him bully but just do
with the necessary Force you what you
need to do to make him understand you
don't have to
by the way the story uh the the the bus
the bully the street corner like yeah
wow ridiculous I'm getting
um uh you know the the Goosebumps but
let's say you did kick the crap out of
him yeah let's say you did do you think
that would have had a better effect
because you saw you said you saw him a
few years later right corner it was too
late I'm sure he is he does not bully
young kid anymore you know I'm sure no
but he it sounds like he's bullying his
own life yeah it sounds like he needed
some sort of ass whooping mental Clarity
to change right because something needs
to happen
for you to change yeah like this guy I
don't we don't know his story but at the
end of the day when he gets this crap
kicked out of him by the guy he used to
bully Something's Gonna Change yeah
clearly you know there's a guy that said
uh uh the teacher gets up there who's
teaching philosophy or something and he
says Hey I want to prove to you guys uh
that God doesn't exist watch this hey if
there's really a god out there you know
I want somebody to come and prove to me
okay that there's a God out there in
front of the you know he's saying this
in front of students anyways I'm
probably paraphrasing and telling a
couple of the story that's the details
not accurate one guy gets up there and
punches him in the face a student the
teacher yeah punches the teacher in the
face he says what the hell was that all
about he says I'm a marine and I wanted
to prove to you that God exists he told
me to come and punch you in the face
okay so the teacher's like
you're out of your mind he says no you
did listen God told me to come he exists
right I think sometimes all of us act
cocky uh every one of us and sometimes
we need to be humbled you know and I
think it happens to all of us and quite
frankly I'm grateful for the people who
humbled me so if somebody wouldn't have
humbled me so to me I like what this guy
is doing because we all need to be
humble at some point of the game uh it's
it as as weird as it sounds you know
what's funny I'm listening to you and
you're talking about the fact that you
know you know you know this whole
situation rights like you know this
thing this whole situation you know how
this is structured all the OCD stuff
right there's a great book for that by
the way two book one of them is called
hypomanic Edge the other one's called
the first-rate madness absolutely
incredible that says why the crazies run
the world because they see World in a
different lens a German philosopher once
said if a lion could speak we could not
understand him because Lions Speak a
different language right now here's a
here's a challenge and I want you to
push back I want to give it to you
disagree with me if you follow like I
don't agree here's why Okay so
I won an interview with Mike Ditka okay
you know Mike Ditka Mike Ditka is one of
the best uh he's he was a coach of the
Chicago Bears
American football yeah yeah
I go interview Mike Ditka and I'm
sitting with them and this guy was the
guy that would call you out he was dark
no he was like a child he was a fighter
he was like you know he was a married
man truly a man's man I'm sitting there
I'm interviewing with him and he starts
becoming apologetic about how tough he
was on people
and I'm like
man I don't know why I don't want to
hear that then I watch a story of Vince
lombardia documentary if you if you
don't know Vince Lombardi is Vince
Lombardi some of them call him the
greatest coach of all time okay
when you win the Super Bowl in in
America they give you a trophy that's
called the Lombardi trophy that's so
because of him right so there's a
document or I don't know if you've seen
it you got to watch this but it's pretty
sick so his wife would say you know we
would put events all the time and then
he would come and entertain whatever I
just got the chills all over my body
says then all of a sudden he would step
away and he would go to his room and he
would start crying Lombardi Lombardi
would cry you can't picture a guy like
that so why are you crying he says
because I feel like I was little tough
too tough on my guys I was a little too
tough on my players I was a little too
tough on my I shouldn't have been that
tough and he's only reliving all the
people he was tough on right and then
they go and interview the players and
the players like [ __ ] we we're grateful
because if it wasn't for a guy that had
these types of expectations we wouldn't
be who we are today so so you know I
feel like sometimes when that Killer
Instinct goes you know maybe you're
right that we're living at a different
phase where it's no longer necessary to
have that killer instinct but if I have
a kid that wants to make it at the
highest level in any realm that he's
playing I think during that time when
he's playing
there there's got to be an element of
Madness when you watch man in the arena
with Brady or you watch Michael Jordan
the Last Dance you watch some of these
guys you're like dude these guys are off
yeah and and I feel like you have to be
off to compete at that level so do you
think for you to be at the point that
you're at it's because you're no longer
competitively uh doing something that
there's a vision to be the greatest in
that space so because of that you have
to kind of leave that to the past and
there's a new chapter coming up I I
think it's meant it's definitely more
mental Than Physical
physically I might not have been as good
as I used to be but I I'm sure if I
would have the same mental that I used
to with the same you know Drive I could
have go back and be very competitive and
maybe be Champion again I don't know
maybe yes maybe no
but I think like you said you need to to
be different and uh you talk about the
past like my old karate teacher that
that I told you uh that introduced me to
Carolina yeah my dad introduced me first
but he was working too much
the way he taught me man he couldn't I
teach her karate instructor cannot teach
the kids the same way they used to
taught me because I would go in jail
they would go in jail but you know why
you know what I'm I'm very happy that he
taught me that way because that's what I
needed that's exactly exactly what you
said and I agree with what you just said
I needed this it was a different era it
was different my dad the way my dad
raised me I cannot I would never be able
to raise kids like this I'll go in jail
you know what I mean now it's it's crazy
you know what I mean you have kids no no
no kids yet no it it's it's crazy I I'll
go in in jail you know what I mean it's
it's a different time different era you
know what I mean it's just uh Pat you're
uh you're a father four kids yeah you
hear what he's saying your father is was
probably the biggest impact on your life
yeah you talk about that openly vocally
he was tough on you uh not physically
though no but never hit me but the way
that he interacted with you yeah
there's a lot of Truth to what he's
saying we even talked about it with the
tennis coach Rick Macy about how tough
he was with he was the coach for Venus
and Serena Williams greatest tennis
voluntary was probably much tougher
voluntary as well yeah okay but we
talked about the effect on kids today as
a father you're hearing this
how are you you know digesting and
processing what he says as a father
tougher back in the day versus what
you're doing my dad and I had a
conversation and you know he's talking
about you know you know it's it's my
fault it's my fault it was this moment
that he and I had I'm like dude dad stop
I said whatever way you raise me you did
the right thing and I'm glad Ford I'm
telling you I would tell you if you
screwed up my dad was freaking like he
expected this I'm like dude I'm so glad
you were the way you were because I
wouldn't be the way I am I think the
challenge here is
the person that's the coach who second
guesses themselves the person who makes
it at the level he makes it who second
guesses themselves like you know maybe
it was too much maybe it was this maybe
it was that no bro you would have never
made it at that level if you didn't
freaking the mental torture a peak
performer goes through to get there I
mean you know some people like well you
know uh the other day uh um uh Brandon
Shaw and Joe were talking about they're
nice enough to say a few words good
words but they were talking about the
fact that hey on the podcast they talk
about levels to athletes right okay so
let's just say like oh you making the
top 10 percent okay there's a very big
difference between being the top 10
anything versus top one percent say
you're making the top one percent oh
very different sacrifices and way of
thinking to go from top one percent to
point one percent then to point one
percent there is the point zero then so
there's always levels but to keep going
to that next level if people knew what
it took to get there 99.9
people wouldn't do the work together
because nothing is guaranteed that
that's the that's the battle and you
know like sales I'll I'll bring young
sales guys it's a lot easier to get
sales younger sales guys to give the
best and work harder because they're
thinking they have a shot at one day
making XYZ but bringing a 50 year old
person and try to tell them the 50 year
old person goes in they're processing
everything more logically they're like
yeah I remember when I got my in their
mind they're telling this no I remember
when I was 20 I got my real estate
license and I gave five years and I
worked so hard nothing happened I lost
that girl yeah I remember when I was 39
years old I started that little you know
restaurant and I put 300 000 and didn't
work you can't convince that guy to pay
the price at 52 years old because he
knows too much sometimes knowing too
much will prevent you from giving your
best for anything old dogs neutral you
know what I'm saying so almost not
knowing and being oblivious is a
freaking gift you say they say something
young dumb is better than being like
older and wisely it's true it's true
you're not aware of the danger of the
wrist to Pat's point this mental this
process that you're going through a
process
I went through this I don't know if you
went through this because you you
matured a little bit uh uh before uh my
but turning 40
right you have a birthday coming up
you're You're Gonna Be 41. You retired
how many years ago it's about five years
okay how much did the number 40 affect
you you're laughing 40 was on my I was
like holy [ __ ] 40. because you've been
great for two decades now since you were
I mean when did you really reach the
Pinnacle age 21 I don't know what it was
I'm not sure I think that your the prime
talk about performance and Sport I think
it's it it's hard to say because
sometimes you have the physicality and
the knowledge you know right and your
knowledge will always increase by your
physicality of course you you know I
mean when the peak meets but you retired
at age 35
37 37
36 36 okay 36 yeah yeah but looking
forward you saw that number 40 and you
said quite clearly I I want the the best
to be behind me I don't want to you know
retire too late what did the concept of
turning 40 do for you
I think it's just sometimes you
physically
and mentally like physically
I feel like I don't recuperate as well
as I used to some little injury
sometimes that that you feel that you
you didn't feel before uh mentally is
it's just a number I guess it's just a
number and and I think as time goes by
they keep pushing back the the age you
know of when you should retire you know
what I mean I remember
it was a an error that when you reach 30
you're like oh you're pretty much you're
at you're at the end of it but now in
combat sport especially when you're 30
years old normally you're in your Prime
right now you know 30 years old so I got
I got a different kind of a question for
you with that age thing so even today so
in your mind uh you're a pretty logical
reasonable guy but you're also pretty
confident guy you got a good balance of
both you don't lack confidence and ego
and you don't lack uh uh logic and being
able to reason today say you said I'm
gonna go train and I'm gonna go bring
the coaches and I'm gonna do real
training like you know how you go at
certain things people like hey did
mazavidal really train this for go up
against this yeah he was really oh
there's this person that guy really
wasn't training no [ __ ] he lost why
didn't he only do one week of training
you kind of processing that right say
you go in three to six months you're
fully prepare to fight okay and say
there is a fight with you against Conor
Oregon's khabib those two names if a
fight was with you against Conor at
their age today and say khabiba green
and said he wants to come back we know
it's not going to happen he said he's
not going to do because when his father
died he promises mom that he's not going
to come back and you're saying 100
you're not going to do it even for 30
million dollars you said you would do
400 million dollars right now for no no
no no but but if if it did and you did
train we know it's not going to happen
but if it did do you think you could
beat O'Connor or a khabib today if you
did go six months training and they did
as well what if I have the the same the
motivation to do it yeah I believe so
even have to say do you think you can
beat
if I have the motivation to go to
another Earth and you don't want to do
it
I don't want to take yeah the beating
two months of my life getting I don't
want to waste too much of my life
doing this I just don't want to put me
through the stress through the the the
the the grind of doing this again do you
want to be in the hunt for another thing
in your life again or are you done being
oh yeah what are you under hunt for like
hunt at that level of a hunt I'm a as a
human being and I'm sure you guys is the
same for you I
the key form is to be happy is to to
reach the to be the person that I want
to be and and I remember when I was a
kid I was looking at myself in the
mirror
and I didn't I did not like what I used
to see I hated I don't I didn't like
myself and I was a kid at that time I
was bullied
I was a kid who lacked a lot of
self-confidence and then I had a good
image of myself
and I I remember
that add a vision
and and I had a vision of who I wanted
to become not I'm not talking about
champion and and physical so I'm talking
about about mental like as a person
and I fall in love with that image that
I want to become
so that's what
helps me to get to to go through my day
at the time when it was hard for me at
the time because I didn't have the
knowledge that I that I have now
and I'm still not that person that
perfect ideal person that I want to
become you know I'm better than I was
but I'm still lacking a lot of a lot of
thing you know for example I'm not a
very patient person I'm more patient
that I used to be but I'm not you know
things like this that the the idea
person that I visualized when I was a
kid and it changed over the year I'm
still not there I still you know I want
to become that person I'm still working
towards it and I'm not talking about
championship and stuff like this just
helped me to become more confident
changing it's bigger than fighting yes
exactly it's better just be the human
the person yeah now I'm more I'm more of
an entrepreneur and more you know it's
different my life has changed but it
mold me to become a different person and
I'm I'm still not there yet I'm still
working to become that person but are
you in a hunt for something outside of
that I mean I understand because even in
life one can be in the hunt for what
you're doing like I as a man I am in the
hunt to really be curious to know what
the 50 year old pbd is going to be I'm
43 right now I can't wait to meet my 50
year old Patrick where David I want to
see what I'm gonna be like I'm so
excited to meet that guy I'm patient the
next seven years it can go as slow as
possible I'm cool with it but I'm
excited about it right I'm looking
forward to it because I want to see what
next develop and I'm gonna have as I
recreate myself but I'm talking about
outside of that
you know are you in the hunt for
something a sport a business like khabib
is doing what he's doing Eddie Hearn and
Jake Paul are sitting there Eddie's
telling JK you're an average boxer at
best but that's still a compliment and
Jake so they're in the hunt for
something you know Dana's in the hunt
for something Joe is in the hunt for
something he's in a podcast game and
he's doing what he's doing right
everybody's in the hunt for something
what are you in the hunt for right now I
believe I
I'm in the aunt to to first to be
healthy this thing is the most I think
to be in order to be happy one of the
most important thing is to be to be
healthy
to be loved to be the love the the
health I think it's part of happiness
and freedom whenever 100 free you know
we always have responsibility and
for me I use
fighting as a benchmark to to have more
freedom to to be able to do what I what
I do
and I'm still not satisfied yet you know
what I mean I'm still working to be more
free to be have more and when I say
freedom it's not necessarily money money
help you to be free because you you you
can buy things and something you can
have a better lifestyle you know a
quality of life through it but that's
not the only thing that makes you happy
you know what I mean and I think that's
what it is and and I have knowledge that
I have now that I'm glad that I have but
I wish I would have had before you know
what I mean stuff I've learned that
changed my life that man I
there's so much stuff like like I wish I
would have you know what I'm asking
though do you know what I'm asking you
know what I'm asking do you know what
I'm asking like here's what I'm asking
like I'm asking I I is there a space not
personal not like Enlightenment which is
I mean we're all searching Enlightenment
because we want to get a little bit more
clarity in Life or free to making more
money but are you because again you're
41 and you're very young right are you
are you in the hunt to give your best to
like for example are we gonna see a GSP
podcast coming out and that's what
you're gonna do for the next few years
because you want to build a podcast and
you want to go out today is it going to
be you know what I I like what uh uh
Dana is doing I feel like I can give
back to the UFC World by doing XYZ I
feel like I can go out there and do
build one of the best training
facilities where young Fighters come and
I shape their mindset and I develop one
of the best schools around the world to
teach trainer to teach Fighters how to
really fight what's that next thing with
you I for me I think
it would be to to pass down my knowledge
you know knowledge uh that I acquire
over the years
um
in order to help
the Next Generation to to get better to
surpass the present generation
and um I think as Einstein he says if I
if I'm if I can see further than my
predecessor is because I I'm standing on
shoulder of giant and it's I think it's
true in sport as well
I I think what I can do to help the next
generation is in a way
for me I'm working now on a project with
doing instructional video I'm gonna
that's one thing I'm gonna do and I'm
gonna be able to to teach my knowledge
to to to certain people that can that it
will help them to not make the same
mistake that I did yeah so they they
have a head start already so that that's
why when you talk about for example
Sport and performance and business
anything
why performance get better it's not
because the guy is better it's because
they have a head start they learn from
their predecessors and I think it's the
same thing in everything and and I think
it's my duty in order to try to help
them to make the world better to to to
to pass down that knowledge who do you
think how I I am able to sometimes I
mentally a lot of guy after they retire
they they become kind of depressed
because they don't have that high
anymore how I overcome that you know I
use fasting and cold and water immersion
to to through this and people are like
ah it's kind of stupid but it's not
super in a way can I explain yeah
sometimes in life some people like they
feel depressed or or you know they have
some problems everybody has problems
even if you don't have that much of a
problem you might feel like you have a
lot of problem but one thing that
helps me
with
fasting and cold water immersion is
these
I put myself voluntary into that stress
when you haven't eat for a certain
amount of days and if you try that to
ask your doctor first for me I helped me
mentally it's very therapeutic
because
when you have a need for a certain
amount of days
it's it's a very uh basic uh thing that
you're fighting you're fighting against
starvation you know what I mean so all
your problems like all your your little
problem will go away and focus only on
the problem that you're fighting of
starvation so so it's not that the
fasting that will
help you that will be therapeutic for
you it's your when you break the fast
when you eat you will it will make you
appreciate life and how it will make you
realize how insignificant those little
problems that you have are same thing
when you're in a cold water immersion
you're fighting hypothermia I think it's
a little ironic as you're talking about
starvation and Pat had to have a little
bite of food right there yeah yeah the
protein but if you believe you will
achieve yeah and I'm really glad that
you kind of
Revisited the conversation because you
said what's the next step with you GSP
and he said well you know I want to be
healthy and you're like no but like what
do you really want and the answer that
you gave was you want a coach you want
to help the youth and that coach uh I
don't have I don't think I have the
patient to be a good coach to to be
one-on-one and go to Coach yeah to pass
down pass down wisdom yes nowadays you
I remember when I wanted to learn Jiu
Jitsu I need to physically attempt a
class of jujitsu that's what that's what
it was in my days when I first started
yeah nowadays a kid can take a cell
phone oh you want to learn you want to
learn oh you look online you know that's
how that's why who do you think is doing
it
right meaning by the way did you see the
breaking news did you see what just
happened right now if you want to pull
this up crazy because everybody's asking
what what your thoughts are on this
uh MMA World react Charles a real Mrs
Wade being stripped of UFC title no way
yeah this just literally happened 20
minutes ago go down to read the article
go a little lower so we can read the
whole thing make it a little bit bigger
Charles Oliver is no longer UFC
lightweight champion after losing a
battle with the skill uh do Bronx failed
to make Championship weight for
scheduled fight UFC 130 230 74 Main
Event title against Justin
coming in 155.5 on two separate attempts
half a pound over the limit just a
freaking half a pound shortly after a
second attempt it was announced that the
lightweight title is vacated and only
gagey is eligible to win in Saturday wow
this is not the first time Oliveira has
had a difficulty at scale though his
previous misses came when he was
competing at a featherweight 155 pounds
uh he has won 10 straight fights I'd
like we captioned UFC title TKO how
disappointing is this to lose it this
way yeah but it is disappointed but we
don't know the whole story that's just
an art what do you mean by that what
what else could be well maybe he got
sick maybe you got food poisoning you
know what I mean there's a lot of X
Factor we don't sometimes we're attempt
to judge something when we see the
headline but we don't know that I think
it's it's sometimes we don't know the
whole story it could be just a lot I
don't think it's a lack of professional
professionalism you know it could be but
you know I have to wait to have more
data on on what happened you know
sometimes I'm
I'm under the impression that yeah it's
it sucks you know like especially if
you're just engage your opponent doesn't
make weight it's not fair but I think in
this situation might be more damageable
for Oliveira because that's mean if you
miss way that's mean you try to remake
what he pushed himself to the limit of
of uh dehydration so maybe his body will
be more messed up especially if it goes
a few more around that it should be you
know what I mean if the fight goes
longer it might have a a very negative
effect on his performance by the way
what was the The Who if you if everybody
if both of them made their way who did
you have winning this fight
I think it was very close I think I
would have gone with uh gaichi you you
would have gone together yeah go against
the earth I think so I I know Justin gay
tree a little bit so I'm biased a little
bit but uh the reason why is
um
recently aloe vera attempt to have
changed a little bit of his style of
fighting he seems to fall in love a lot
with
is striking you know what I mean and
he's a great Striker but he's almost
like a cowboy Chandler yes exactly but
but that's why so I think is his main
chance of winning the fight the best the
smartest way to win that fight against
uh gaichi would be to take gechi out of
his comfort zone and if he does that
it's goodbye it's finished but I think
I'm under the impression that sometimes
he
get cut in these emotions that he wants
to trade you know a strike for strike
you know I don't know if it's for the
fans or if you just forgot his his game
plan he did that is the last few recent
fights and and I'm under the impression
that if he does that with Justin Gage
it's a bad idea it's like flipping a
coin you know you don't want to make the
fighter coin to us you know what I mean
especially if you know there is a
specific area that you can bait your
opponent you want to go there you don't
want to make the fight let me ask you
what does Dana White do now what what
does he do last minute I mean this is a
tough place to be because yes he can't
replace that fight it's done right that
fight is off so the main fight becomes
Chandler Ferguson is that is that what
happens is the next car just comes up
meaning does the next fight just come up
as a main fight I I no no I I think that
the it's I think it stays the same as
just the fight one if if uh Oliver
Olivero wins it won't it won't be he
won't so the fight's still gonna happen
I think so I think so normally what they
do is is they keep the fight but if
Olivero win he's not winning the belt
even if he's still Champion he's the
belt is out now because he didn't make
weight but but Justin also doesn't get
the Bell now Justin do get the belt if
he wins he has the belt yes he do no no
but if Charles win if Charles when he
doesn't get the belt but Justin also
doesn't get the belt now Justin if
Justin wins he will become Champion I
get it but if Charles wins Justin
doesn't become the champion the belt is
out that Charles doesn't have it no
nobody is Champion a it's vacant it's
called vacant yeah
wow so it's a big punishment but it's
it's you know we're not half a pound
yeah half a pound and also depending
where you fight normally there's a
certain percentage of your purse of of
your show showpers because normally most
Fighters they get paid for showing for
just show up yeah and for the win so for
your show personally which is not all
the time but depending what is your
contract could be like half half of your
purse goes like maybe not F but like
maybe 30 of half of your purpose goes to
Europe this is gonna be such a Layman's
question but I feel bad for the guy half
a pound like that sucks I feel bad for
any athlete do you feel bad for the guy
no I do not feel bad for a guy
um it's your duty your responsibility to
be in weight to be on to be on on the
dot
sometimes though there's things that you
don't control maybe the the the skill
that he was using is is messed up you
know maybe half a pound maybe he got you
got you got the sick that that week and
he decided to you know for each reason
and I [ __ ] I'm still taking the fight
you know we all have done it in the past
you know what I mean maybe you don't
feel bad for this guy I don't feel bad
but until we have more
more data on the situation we'll we'll
see more who is it was to blame you know
fair enough what's the reaction Ben is
is Twitter reacting to this or no like
have you seen what folks are saying
Justin said what did he say let me see
poor bass are still cutting I'm back at
uh 65 while he's dying he better make it
he has five minutes he had already put
on 10 pounds after he made weight Justin
did you know again let's see what Justin
looks like
he already put on 10 pounds yeah
um
interesting to say
Conor McGregor was mentioned misses his
weight
wow this is this is uh it'll be
interesting to see what happens I I
think uh because this was this was one a
lot of people were looking forward to in
the Ferguson fight with Chandra who do
you think is going to take that one
shoot it's it I don't know we'll take it
but I can tell you
statistically speaking I believe if it's
a short fight if it finish in the first
round it's because of Chandler but if it
goes past the the first maybe second
round is gonna be Ferguson I believe I
don't know a lot of fights I've seen
with Chandra where I don't don't
appreciate the first round yeah
he almost took everybody so explosive
but Ferguson is so tough man he let his
arm broke the the against Oliver it's
crazy it's sometimes it's hard to watch
man I have man I just I just hope
sometimes I mean I just hope on The
Human Side that nobody get hurt badly
and the best man win you know what I
mean when you say when you say it's hard
to watch that particular fight or UFC
fights in general no no no that that
particular fight I remember uh
Ferguson Olivero he let his arm broke
I'm like man it was hard to watch you
know it was completely hyper extended
you saw the The Joint like bending on
the other side I mean it's hard to watch
for me I mean for me the way I see it
it's a sport and and we all do that to
to to make to make a living and
it's hard to watch when you see guys I
get punished very hard after they they
you know they go back to their lives or
whatever families oh yeah I watch it but
don't I don't watch all the fights I I
watch only the guys who do you enjoy
watching like this card it's it's it's
amazing it's gonna be very stack I loved
it I like uh khabib is returner but I
like uh wokanovsky I like uh Olivero I
like kamaru Usman uh all the champion
Francis and ganous
do you like watching counter fight when
he was oh yeah I love it I love Conor
because he brings a certain element of
emotion and to it that nobody really is
able to to do at that same level do you
think he'll be a champion you think
he'll get back to the top again it could
but it's gonna be hard man I mean he's
on a losing straight now I mean he lost
his last three fights he can definitely
do it if he but I think
you know it it's hard to go to the
buffet when you already eat before yeah
let me just kind of put put things in
perspective let me just put your things
in perspective your career earnings UFC
I just searched it seven million dollars
is that about right career earnings
you're not not sponsorships outside no
no but you I did a lot more what did UFC
pay you yeah I did a lot more the the
thing is that people don't know is we
have a show purse yeah like that where
my contract was at a Shoppers at a
winning purse but I will also
um when I used to fight back then back
in the day I had the percentage of the
pay-per-view buys oh no [ __ ] was part
yeah of course okay it was part of my
contract
nowadays I think it's it's different
because the ufcs I think give that right
to ESPN and I don't know for how long it
is so what the fighters it's sad because
a lot of them they don't have as much
power so you made more money back in the
days and today I think I think because
of the infrastructure of how it was made
I think the fighters had more power
before so I'm very lucky to be to have
been competing during that era of time
uh you know Conor McGregor obviously is
the one that I think made the biggest
earning in the sport
um because he touched the pay-per-views
um I think I don't I don't have the
statistic in front of me but I know like
Ronda Rose is there too she was amazing
she made great for for herself in terms
of of of gain of uh I think Brock Lesnar
is there could be but you know what I
mean and just very
feel very fortunate to have competed
during that era of time if I would have
done it during rice Gracie Mark Coleman
it was terrible they were underpaid like
so bad right and if it if it's now now
the problem is they
they have power but they don't have as
much power as we used to have when we
could touch the piece of the pie you
know what I mean some fighter does but I
don't think they have as much leverage
in negotiation it's kind of sad yeah do
you think like if you look at what's
evolved within the UFC world uh PD's
always been a topic of discussion people
were throwing you know left and right
was it more of a topic of discussion
early on the early early days or you
kind of got away with it back in the
then was it more in the 2000 was it it
was a topic of discussion all the time
but the thing is it was so much in your
face that for me it wasn't it was an
insult you know what I mean like like I
I
it's still there's still a problem we're
not gonna lie there's still a problem
there's still uh you know that
it's it there's still a there's still a
problem there will always be but it's
much better now now they're testing the
fighters but there are still ways that
you can cheat it's it's kind of easy you
know way to cheat in a way you know what
I mean
we all have a car that we fill up that
it's called a whereabout you tell them
where you are and every time you you can
lie on that that whereabouts you can't
or you no you can't you can't lie and if
they show up to test you they say that
they're gonna ring you and say hey we're
there to test you where are you you know
what I mean and you you can you know
what I mean you just have to don't I
think it's trees two or three three
strike you can have so you know what I
mean
the guys that does uh use performance
enhancing drugs that they're they have
ways of of you know the system also
could be corrupted sometimes you know
what I mean when there is money involved
there there is always corruption a
little bit so it's much better than it
used to be but it's not perfect but it's
much better you know they made they did
a good job well the concept of fighter
pay that's something we've been
discussing pretty openly we had Francis
naganu right here uh you've interviewed
Dustin Poirier you've we've had uh uh
sugar Rashad Evans in here we've you've
been on Rogan
um we've had these discussions on
fighter pay uh you've broke down the
ebitda of what UFC is
um but you're saying that fighter pay
today could be better or what are your
thoughts on that oh yeah it could be
better 100 it could be better it could
always be better
we like we are like I feel
um the baseball player or occupy I know
hockey because I'm from Canada
in the days that they were underpaid you
know before they had the the union to
protect them you know it's the same
thing in in fighting one day there will
be a union to protect Fighters it has to
be it doesn't doesn't make sense very
interesting concept right there because
there's the you know NFL PA there's the
NBA they've got their Union the baseball
why is there no Union in the UFC
fighting well everybody want to be in
control and I think it's it's
when there's money there's always a
conflict and stuff you know and I I
that's why they asked they have been
some organization that have tried to do
it but they it was conflicting with
others and and that's very unfortunate
but the the
reason of why they want to do it it's
it's great it's a great great reason you
know it's it's a it's a non it's it's a
it's a very good good one I think it
will happen one day a hundred percent
and very often it's funny I have some of
the some of the parent they come with
their kids they're like hey George this
is my son he's a future world champion
of UFC what advice would you give him I
tell the kid I say you're doing well at
school stay at school yeah yeah train if
you want you know what I mean train you
know do it and if you but don't put all
your eggs in the same basket thinking
that you're gonna make it because
statistically
you're going against the Earth big time
is one guy on maybe a hundred thousand
maybe even more you know and I'm not
talking about fighting I'm talking about
basketball okay same thing same thing
fighting is even worse because get
punched in the head you know like
American football very very bad too so
what I said to the kids yeah try to make
it but don't give up school don't give
up school because at least
if you're
30 years old or late 20s and you found
out that you cannot make it for X reason
if you don't have education that you
have nothing that you can fall back into
but if you do have education at least
you you have an assurance you know what
I mean it's very important very very
important I I see in the gym where I
train it's one of the places I love to
go because it it's very therapeutic for
me I love it I love the science to go
train but it's very sad would you have
liked it if somebody gave you that
advice when you were 14 yes people give
me the advice but do you do you do you
how did you take it when you were 14
when somebody said that to you I took it
I I listen I I stopped school I stopped
I was in university in kinesiology
and I stop it when I had my first title
shot and I told my parent because my
parent always put School in priority
they say Georgie not Never Gonna Leave
School
and and and until you you live through
our supervision you know what I mean
we're always going to push you to school
and and as and I thought it was a great
you know but when I had my first title
shot at that time I was working like
crazy I had like two three jobs studying
at school and part-time and in the same
time and I wanted to achieve my dream
was to become world champion when I
thought Matt used before I thought that
you might use the first time a few few
months before I told my parents I say is
it okay if I if I stop this this session
and I go back if things doesn't turn out
I go back next session because if if I
miss this opportunity it's my dream to
accomplish that to become Champion I I
have to train full time to put to put
all my the chance of on my side and my
parents says yes go for it you know and
the the reality is a lot of the
people when I go train in the gym they
come to me and they want to have advice
from me they say George what should I do
and sometimes I'm like oh yeah when you
throw your punch I give them technical
advice but the real advice sometimes I
should give them but I cannot do it
because they're gonna think of me being
an arrogant prick I should tell them I
say hey
Mr X
you're 33 years old you've been losing
your last three fights it's sad I'm sad
to to announce you that you're not gonna
make it you're not gonna go in UFC and
even if you if you make it
your best years are behind you you know
it's finished you should keep training
but find yourself a real job you know
like like a real goal and like and it's
sad because I will see their dream
shattered on on in their eyes and I
don't want that meet that person that
that that tell them that and it's very
sad because it's a movie that I've seen
many times is a very very bad ending
you're gonna finish physically broken
and and financially broken as well you
know what I mean it's very sad it we
only talk about the people that makes it
but there's a lot a lot more
people that does not make it the odds
are against you it's the reason why I
was able to make it it's it's yeah
people say you work hard I work hard but
the stars were aligned I was lucky and
fortunate enough to meet the right
person at the right time the path with
was open for me I made it you know maybe
if one of the of these little thing
changes I would never have made it you
know what I mean you know you don't know
maybe you can have a car accident and
get hit and never be able to compete or
never come back the same I had an ACL
tear I remember
um was about uh 10 years ago I had ACL
Terror the doctor told me he said you
know George for that if you would have
had the same injury
a few years back it would be a career
ending so sometimes life is the line is
so so tiny you know what I mean it's one
thing influence another thing and this
you know what I mean that the odds are
against you so
you need to have an assurance education
as somebody who's from Canada what do
you think about uh uh Justin Trudeau and
what's been happening with Canada Canada
last couple years I think it's uh man
it's uh
for me I've been traveling and it's it's
it I always felt better when I go home
and everything is closed the business
are closed and
I think they were more
conservative in a way that they wanted
to to protect people but I don't think
if it was I don't know if it was a great
choice you know what I mean because I
see
I don't have this test stick in front of
me but I I see the world around me but I
and from what I've seen what I can judge
is the
like people here business-wise they're
more happy than they were they are back
home during the the
during the the pandemic you know I see
more happiness here maybe it's because I
don't live here but I come very often
then back home you know so South Florida
or towards Miami yeah Florida Texas even
in UK everywhere I go they they bit
their business as maybe not as collapse
as much you know what I mean so it's
fair to say that Justin Trudeau's
policies have not been beneficial to the
people of Canada
I I maybe it has been beneficial for
protecting lives I guess
Health but not maybe for business you
know what I mean it's hard to you know
it's depend how you see it you know
independent depend what you you support
the most you know I'm more a guy in my
life I take risk in my life I'm more a
guy that take risk you know so maybe me
I would go more towards a risk-taking uh
politic you know like like a
solution you know what I mean because
I'm more willing to take risk that's
part of my personality but maybe someone
who's more conservative who's afraid it
will be more on the other side you know
what I mean since you're retired for the
last three or four years have you found
yourself
gravitating more towards politics
towards business towards Sports in
general like where have you actually
spent your time focusing on
I transformed myself I I've been taking
acting classes uh it's been more than
four years now I was a very fortunate I
had opportunities that Falcon and the
Winter Soldiers on Disney plus I just
finished
um shooting a movie in in UK now I was
at a small roles so I um I uh I work on
my on my acting skills it's a lot of fun
yeah and I have a I'm more of an
entrepreneur now I'm I'm helping
promoting a
fitness equipment that we call Base
block that was that sells online
um a line of food food supplement as
well a wire from heart and soil it's a
heart and liver so I'm more I check my
life changed more towards that side how
are your acting skills right now why is
getting it's much better than it used to
be and acting is like fighting
it takes a lot of practice and I was
acting all my life like I said I was
afraid before every fight but when you
see me come out I look like I'm excited
to be there and I was acting putting on
an act and same thing in acting and and
fighting you rehearse it's a lot of
rehearsing but in fighting when you re
when you practice a lot of situation
that can happen in a fight you find out
quickly enough that when you're in a
fight
your opponent is Never As Good As you
think he was and he's never as bad he's
always different same thing in acting
you can rehearse a scene as much as you
want but when you get on set the
background might the background might be
different the reaction of the actor with
who you're playing might be different so
you have to be like Bruce Lee said be
like water ready to adapt I think the
best actor and the best athlete are the
one that can adapt the best bee water
but that's a cool water my friends
that's exciting to see you go in that
direction let's do a couple colors here
guys I need to go use the Russian yes
I might be the first one that ever no no
no you're the fourth
I drink too much water give me give me
30 seconds I'm gonna speed water I gotta
pee can we can we set him up make sure
there's a bathroom available
listen you have no idea how cool it is
even Fighters gotta use the bathroom
we've had we've had I think four or five
people in total yeah become officially
members of the soybean Mafia and have to
use but you kicked it off you started
the whole thing tradition then it was uh
the best dog so would you what you think
about some of the stuff he was talking
about I tell you I got goosebumps when
he talked about when he saw the guy uh
the homeless guy on the street
and and he talked about the father his
father going to the guy's house because
he ratted on him what have you and he
saw the what what the kid was truly
dealing with a drunk abusive father and
that was the reason that he was lashing
out with him on the bus
he's a deep dude man and we talked about
this at the beginning he's a he's not
just a he's not just a guy talking to AI
he's into dinosaurs he's into the most
interesting things he's a he's not a uh
he's not a regular guy the challenge you
know sometimes you you you see the a
person that makes it to the highest
level and then at that point
you know you the the challenge then
becomes when you know you're talking to
the kids are coming up to him hey you
know this is like hey focus on schools
and focus on do this
becomes uh it becomes you I read a book
one time that says uh uh about guilt
never feel guilty about the price others
have to pay to win at the highest level
never feel guilty about the highest
price everybody else has to pay to and
at the highest level right sometimes as
a parent or as a businessman or somebody
that gives your best you're like [ __ ]
man I know how much money how much they
need to put into it you don't want to
see another person have to put that kind
of sacrifice into it anyways uh uh sorry
guys good it's all good if we got the
callers let's get the callers in if
they're ready John if you got callers
we're ready here I haven't eaten
anything today except some little fruit
and I drink too much water I guess it's
got you whatever you wanted George all
right uh we have Chase on the phone
perfect Chase how you doing
we can barely hear you buddy so whatever
you're doing you just kind of uh left us
for a second
still can't hear you
John maybe let's get to the next caller
for somebody that we can hear go ahead
Johnny
sure
yeah it looks like we're not getting uh
you got the next one
thereon is just that the audio is pretty
low yeah something's wrong with the auto
you can just keep it moving okay you you
fought Carl uh uh Parisian how was that
when you fought Cara Cara was a badass
coming up he was fun to watch oh yeah he
uh man it was my first fight in UFC and
I man I was so excited to be there at
the time but I was so scared at the same
time I think I'm saying it's excited
because because that's the word that we
use but in reality it's scared I was
scared and um I know he's a Armenian
Arrow Parisian and uh he
he had one crazy good weapon that we
knew it was this Kimura Kimura constant
yes the camera is a lot that you do you
can break the Rotator off of the
shoulder he is so good with that
particular move that everybody knows
that he's good at it but nobody is able
to stop him and I I knew going into that
fight that was his main like the bread
is bread and butter and I and I got cut
in his Kimura in that fight but I was
able to to get out luckily for me but it
was cool that was a that was an
incredible fight by the way who's in
your top five Nelson Rodriguez Jr just
asked who's your top five if you were to
name the top five and you know the
greatest of all time hujab on that list
uh I think the number one for me is
Royce Gracie because uh of course
if you put him in the Octagon right now
you would have you would not have do so
well because sport have changed but for
his time I think for me was the greatest
of all time things that you have done it
will never be done again I mean maybe
not of my living I think you can put a
Dimitri Demetrius Johnson
you can put
Mark Coleman probably
can put Jon Jones of course Anderson
Silva these guys
um
The Pride Grand Prix at the time yeah
Japan it was so he was the best of the
best the natural follow-up to that is
because if you so remove your ego from
the situation right GSP everyone would
put you in their top five everybody do
you feel uncomfortable putting yourself
on that list no no no I I understand I
I'm in the the list but the the
the greatest of all time it depends it
varies it's a very subjective thing the
thing is in a sport like fighting is
very subjective who's better Ali or or
Tyson who's better you know what I mean
and fighting we cannot measure
performance however if I ask you who's
the fastest printer you're gonna have to
tell me that it is Usain Bolt there is
no choice right you know why because we
can measure same thing in lifting uh the
sport that you have an instrument of
measure you have to go with the result
it's written
and fighting is different and we we
often feel sometimes that the fighters
of the past are better than the one
today very often but I think it's
illogical to think that way and as hard
and painful it is for me because I
retire
I believe the fighters of today are
better than the one of yesterday but the
fighter of tomorrow and of the future
will be even better so the real goat is
not even born yet and it's not because
the guys are better it's because they
are standing on shoulders of giant they
benefit they have a head start because
they they learn from their predecessor
the technology that this stuff we just
talk about how you can learn from a cell
phone nowadays it's crazy I can learn
from with a cell phone Jiu Jitsu moves I
couldn't do that back in the day I had
to go to from Montreal to drive to New
York to learn these these skills you
know what I mean so things are different
so if I would take rice Gracie and put
him putting him today with the
technology the knowledge that he would
benefit maybe would be just as good or
maybe better than anybody uh here in the
in the present day you know but there is
no way to find out by the way last topic
here before we wrap up with uh the
direction UFC is going you see Kobe
masvidol Connor Dustin some of the smack
talking ways that's going on how they
talk trash to each other part of it is a
show is there a line one shouldn't cross
when it comes down to smack talking
because when you guys were doing you
know who was the biggest smack talker
when you were in your 20s uh uh who
would you say was the biggest smack
talker would you say uh maybe it wasn't
even in your class was there anybody
they said this guy wouldn't stop talking
trash non-stop this is an interesting
interesting question that you brings
um for me I know that it's a mental
Warfare especially in fighting because
we don't play games the outcome of a of
a loss or a win it can change your life
and I'm not talking about physical
injuries I'm talking about money you
know you you win a lot more money and
you gain a lot more opportunity
opportunities if you win than if you
lose it's crazy the outcome is I have a
profound effect on an individual and is
is surrounding
therefore knowing this
there is no line to cross and I know
some fighter will cross that line
me you can say whatever you want to me
maybe because of my experience with
bullying I'm used to put on a mask and a
shield on me so it comes and it deflects
or it goes to one here and it goes out
no problem
however if you start talking [ __ ] about
my my family now it's different problem
so that's why
I knowing this about myself I always
deflected family question like stuff
like oh yeah uh like like like like
father or like like everything family I
don't talk about it nobody knows about
me it's the thing that I'm the most
proud of but is my is is my treasure and
I'm in the fighting game it's different
game than basketball game yeah and
people will try to make you derail they
might try to make you lose your mind and
I can give you example of
that Sugar Ray Leonard against Roberto
Duran
when they fought in Montreal
I believe
that Sugar Ray Leonard is a much better
boxer than than Roberts around I mean I
mean at this level it's it's very close
but I believe Leonard is better but when
they fought in Montreal
Zoran insulted the wife of of uh sugary
Leonard Leonard goes crazy he wanted to
show that he's a man so he stood up and
he changed the way he fought because he
became emotional when Conor McGregor won
the first fight against Jose Aldo same
thing
become emotional he wanted to he became
a new rage tried to give him he never
did that he Leap Forward like crazy
tried to knock him out with one punch
McGregor is an amazing counterpuncher 12
seconds left boom finish same thing with
khabib when Conor McGregor tried to do
the same thing with kebi talking about
his religion yes his religion is that
and stuff like that
so some fighter will will cross that
line that's why I never expose my family
never every interview is Never Gonna you
know what I always deflected deflect
what would make this try to get into
your skin Nick was uh uh remember that
one time you guys had an exchange what
are you talking about they don't have
the information okay they don't have the
data to get under him ask him they
cannot give it I never make that
available to them I never make that I
never
showcase this part of my life because
it's that part of my life I am the most
proud of is my treasure that the mo I'm
talking about all my achievement my my
career is this is nothing but but I
never expose this because to protect me
yeah because I mean I'm in that business
it's a hard business and it's hardcore
business but I don't want that part of
me being exposed George crazy question
so your record your record is what 26
and 2 26 and 2 or 28 and two at the end
it's one of those two right yeah it's
hard
what's crazy is both of the losses you
came back and I think you beat Matt two
or three times and you beat Sarah but
but the question is the following say
those fights were no gloves and it was
in the street with the same exact 28
fights would your record still be 26 and
two or would be better would be much
better you think so 100 can you tell me
why his first in street fight I have a
lot of experience in street fight I've
been in many street fight when I was
young you know and it's same thing it's
about the element of surprise if you
have the element if you're the aggressor
you do not have the element of surprise
and street fight is different than
fighting and I have a lot of experience
if you're the nice guy being a nice guy
will give you a head start because in
street fight when you feel the heat
rising you have the element of surprise
to start and and and and and and and do
this and fighting if you if you have the
element of surprise it's a huge huge
Advantage so your record would have been
better than 100 first and and also would
be very very good because of my style of
fighting I was very good every time you
you start a fight you start every time
the round ends you have to start you
know like another fight you know me I
was always better at starting very
strong but sometimes what breaks the
momentum is the round then they restart
again you know what I mean so you would
have preferred 10 minute rounds and five
minutes I would prefer a 25 minute
straight straight on I think that's how
it should be I think the reason why
there is round and and I think the
reason why there is round because to
make the sport legal they needed to make
it look a little bit like boxing boxing
yeah if you want to see who's the best
man Let Them Fight Let them fight with
no realm and I think that would be you
know there's a different way of judging
it but that's how it should have been
what's the surprise move that you that
you that you would use you're saying
that I mean you maybe you can't tell it
but
you're saying like you're saying you'd
be better because the element of
surprise yeah in a street fight there
there's a but in a in a yeah in a street
fight it's it never start with a referee
that you know what I mean like this but
in in the in the street
yeah in a street fighter that's why you
have the limit I'm sorry but I was very
good at knowing when when I felt the
heat rising yeah you would attack that
first one yeah and you're saying when
people were talking trash or you think
that they were gonna hit you and that
you're like the quiet guy back exactly
but very often when I was in schoolyard
it was not only one guy after me was
like two three guys in there they were
older than me so why the hell were they
picking on you so much bro what were you
doing when you're able
I was not a cool guy guys I was gang
before we wrap up this is your last
chance for Super Chat a bunch of you
guys have already done we're about to do
the raffle in three minutes if you do
want to participate in the raffle and
get your name in there uh go ahead and
put it in there for some of you guys
that are wondering about Charles
Oliveira we already talked about that
earlier uh and a bunch of other topics
uh in regards to khabib at the beginning
we talked about how much it would take
to get him in the ring with khabib
you're gonna need to go back and watch
exactly what the answer to that was
Michael Bisping Michael Bisping was also
one that was good at getting under
people's skin right very good yes
somebody said here he imitate imitated
you do you know how to imitate him
you bloody bastard
what a prick
I was with Michael Bisping quite
recently I was in Manchester we had a
drink together it was really it was
recently yeah we were like a movie or
documentary come out about his life
where his eyes it's very good yeah it's
very good and it is a lot of fun to hang
out with I mean yeah yeah I mean I mean
a lot of stuff has been said but I
behind all this fugazi things is there's
a human and I always have a good time
catching up with some of my adversaries
anybody you guys that you guys don't get
along till today or no everybody
yourself there's nobody today there's
absolutely nobody that I've fought that
if let's say I would drive my car and I
would see them on the side side having a
problem I would stop for every one of
them you have no beef no beef wouldn't
and I don't I and I don't think anybody
has beef with me I don't think so all
the stuff that have been said and done
even if it was very edges it was only
for business for me it's not personal so
the next trip is you got to take a trip
to Stockton California
I wish you the best of luck and
everything I don't hold any Grudge
nothing I really do I really wish him I
hope if he come decides to come to come
back and he did last time it didn't look
good but I I hope if he does it for the
right reason he has the motivation I
wish him the best I wish him I love
watching those guys fight was there
anybody when you were coming up you
watched fight that you said dude this
guy had the goodies to become very very
great like was there anyone that you
felt we never saw the best of him when
he was coming up same here as you
uh there's a lot of guys a lot of guys
I've seen especially in the gym that are
that were very talented very good but
they never made it because they
I don't know if it's mentally they they
couldn't pull the trigger they there's a
lot of these guys like you just talk
about there's a lot of these guys so
that's why second funnel there's so many
guys that has potential but
when you narrow it down is only one that
made it sometimes the stars are just
aligned better for one guy I I don't
know I I'm
you know I believe like people like oh
yeah you work hard but you made your yes
but it's not necessarily true I don't
agree with that 100 I believe there's a
lot of
I believe in the causality I believe
there is cause and effect and that I
believe or ignorance
sometimes made it in a way that we call
certain things chances but I don't
believe there is chances I believe it's
there's always a cause and by definition
if there is a cause there is
no free will in a way it's kind of weird
to think about it but that's almost like
we got a our own UFC philosopher uh on
our heads I told you he's deeply what's
the story with Dinosaurs why do you like
dinosaurs I like dinosaurs I've always
been fascinated
by dinosaurs because when I was young I
was drawing monster and what looks the
most like a Monsters the dinosaurs and
and I believe
if you know about the past it helps you
understand the future and sometimes
helps you predict the future you know
what I mean if you know about the past
it helps you understand the present and
helps you sometimes predict the future
well you know we are standing on the
shoulders of giant dinosaurs I don't
know if you're in Florida is that what
it was T-Rex in Florida I I have one
quick question one guy I'm obsessed with
this guy T-Rex we're not in Florida
we're in the west part he's teasing you
he's trying to happen
of giant dinosaurs yeah in general uh
but I have one guy that I'm obsessed
with these days I want to get your
thoughts on this guy Patty the Baddie
piglet what are your thoughts on this
guy yeah I met him briefly in in England
in Manchester too yeah he's very
charismatic yeah
um he's good he's he to be a successful
to be successful in this business of
fighting you need to be skilled but more
than that you need to be charismatic and
in order to be charismatic a lot of guys
feel that they need to trash talk to it
to imitate Conor McGregor but you don't
have to do that I sold a lot of
pay-per-view because I was just
authentic to who I am and I think Patty
the Baddie is is very authentic yeah I
think it's a very charismatic guy he's
got a weird style I really enjoy
watching him fight and I think he's
he's gonna be us he's still a star but
he's gonna be even more of a of a big
draw you know what I mean I think the
sky is the limit and I think he is being
authentic I don't think it's an act no
it's not an act but there is guys that
it you could clearly see it's an act
it's unfortunate because they shoot
themselves in the foot when they do that
you know yeah yeah because it doesn't
work for them doesn't work for them and
to be it's got to be natural you need to
be like you are like like and sometimes
it's not necessarily malish in a
malicious way you we all do this
for the best of our own interests and
some guys they will do this because they
know that's the best
the best way they can help themselves to
achieve what they want to achieve you
know what I mean it's not I don't see it
necessarily in a malicious way even like
like you see like sometimes Conor
McGregor will say stuff that are very
edgy I mean for me it's it's it's it
could become personal because you will
attack your personal life but it's it's
it's it's business in a way you know
what I mean last question uh the UFC who
could replace Dana White I've asked this
question from quite a few different
people just curious you know what's your
thoughts on this man I don't think I
mean everybody
Daniel Cormier he said Daniel couldn't
do my job but who do you think could
replace it I don't think nobody can
replace Dana White I don't think so I
mean to do to be as good as Dana White
was I think some someone can come and
fill the hole
maybe not be like Dana White be better
at certain things that Dana White maybe
sometimes I know it is not very
diplomatic so it could be
it could be more diplomatic but maybe to
to be a promoter to to be intense as as
unique as Dana White is only one guy is
Dana White it doesn't mean his job
cannot be taken and he cannot be run
place I think everybody can be run place
but nobody everybody is unique and
everybody has a different unique
personality and dynamite is is very
Charisma he's in the unique category yes
let's do the raffle Okay Tyler if we're
ready uh we got a bunch of guys that did
100 of this gonna go to uh George Saint
Pierre Foundation one person's gonna get
this set this up for Success what's
gonna happen right now someone's gonna
get uh
glove by GSP okay is that it or is it
gonna go to Zuniga who is it JJ Carlin
Carlin congratulations to you Jay Carlin
uh send us an email uh put the
information there you're gonna get this
glove being sent to you congrats to you
uh this was great uh uh uh GSP uh what a
great story you got it's been a pleasure
having you on man I've really enjoyed it
and thank you thank you for the
opportunity guys thank you yes final
thoughts if guys want to find you you
know is there any project you're working
on right now you want to share with
people I think got something going on
with Warrior yeah maybe some more stuff
you got coming up yeah man people that
are interested investigating about
animal-based diet I mean uh I have a
line of supplement with heart and soil
it's called Warrior line it's heart and
liver that has been desiccated in a
process called dry freeze and uh it's
great for uh because in the western part
of the world we don't really eat organs
but if you go see see out on together uh
tribe lives that's the first thing they
go for when they when they kill an
animal so it's very interesting anyway
this could help a lot of people and also
uh with uh fitness equipment the base
blocks the the pro line so you can go
check it out online let's put the link
below let's let's find the link and
let's put the link below for people to
be able to get it uh GSP thank you so
much for coming on this was a blast
appreciate you buddy take care everybody
we don't have anything till next week do
we have pontus Tuesday Morning Tuesday
morning we'll do podcasts with you take
care guys bye-bye bye bye